The size and the shape base of
organization in Asian cities
has drastically transformed
the physical and socioeconomic
landscape.
Urban population in East Asia
have increased 3% per year
while urban land expansion
reached 2.4% per year.
This strain is intensifying
and has destroyed many places
of historical significance.
Demand for real
estate development
has turned traditional villages
into modern high rise buildings
that are disconnected from
the lifestyles of existing
inhabitants.
In many cases,
communities have not
been involved in the
process of deciding
how development should proceed.
This video presents
how a Malay community
in Kuala Lumpur,
Malaysia responds
to a recent redevelopment effort
of their village Kampong Bharu.
The concerns and aspiration
of the long-term residents,
land owners, and
community leaders
were documented to identify
their vision of the future
of the urban village.
Kampong Bharu sits in the
heart of the Kuala Lumpur
metropolitan region.
A kampong is defined
as a Malay village
or locality with
10,000 or fewer people
under the leadership
of Village Heads.
Kampong Bharu was
formed in the early 1900
when His Royal Highness,
the Sultan of Sulaiman,
granted the land to the Malay's
under a special condition
that the land could only be
owned by the Malay people.
The 223 acre Malay
agricultural settlement
survived under British Colonial
rule and Japanese occupation.
As a Malay enclave,
traditional Malay houses,
microscale businesses,
local food and delicacies
has shaped its unique character.
As Kuala Lumpur develops,
the 116 year old kampong
is now surrounded by high
rise structure, including
the iconic Petronas Tower
and modern office buildings.
Despite piecemeal
development and extension
of commercial and
residential units,
the kampong still looks
similar to its early years.
Meanwhile, with only 35% of the
original residents remaining,
the area has become occupied
mainly by immigrants.
With the rising
land value, the area
has been subjected to the
real state development
scheme that would maximize
the economic potential
of the properties.
However, redevelopment
efforts have
been futile due to the issues
of multiple land ownership, land
price disparities,
and resistance
from residents and land owners.
The initiative to redevelop
the land resurfaced in 2012.
With a strong commitment
from the government,
a comprehensive
development master plan
was prepared by the Kampong
Bharu Development Corporation.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
Under parliamentary Act 733,
Kampong Bharu Development
Corporation was
established the facilitate
the development of the area.
The vision is to develop and
to transform the real estate
in creating a better living
standard while balancing
the requirement of
preserving Kampong Bharu
historical values,
culture, and legacy.
With a mission that
no land owner or heir
of Kampong Bharu land will be
left behind in this development
beyond 2020.
Inspired by the Malay
and Islamic culture,
the master plan seeks to
ensure holistic, inclusive,
and balanced planning that
benefits the key stakeholders.
Recent visits indicate that
transformation of Kampong Bharu
is now underway.
But how do the community
leaders, land owners,
and residents respond to
the redevelopment plan?
What are their aspiration for
the future of the village?
Will the local community
benefit from early development?
Zamri Mohd Saharin,
the deputy director
of urban planning of Kampong
Bharu Redevelopment Corporation
said that the change would offer
economic and social benefits.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
Despite the advantage mentioned,
the Kampong Bharu community
is struggling to come to terms
with redevelopment plans.
As the skepticism and
resistance persist,
understanding the
aspiration of the community
may shed light on the
community's concern.
Conversation with the
land owners, residents,
and community leaders
of Kampong Bharu
highlight that various
concern and expectations.
Land owners embrace the idea
of change and redevelopment
as long as it
conforms to the needs
and aspiration of the Malays.
The economic sustainability
and the continuity
of social and cultural
identity of the Malays
were the main concern
regarding the development.
The Village Heads
had their own views
on how the future of
Kampong Bharu should be.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
Several land owners insisted
that the development
should reflect the Malay
Islamic character and values
in a modern form.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
Islamic and Malay city center.
That's [INAUDIBLE].
A Malay town.
And the first of its
kind in the whole world.
[NON-ENGLISH]
New development should
bring about positive change
for a community.
The land owners realize
the need to improve
the socioeconomic
status of the Malays,
but they were not convinced
that the development
could benefit the community.
The chairman of the
Secretariat of Trade
and Businesses of Kampong
Bharu expressed his concern
about the
redevelopment approach.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
On the other hand, a
Malay real state developer
was confident that the
Malay will reap the benefit.
The need is to have
suitable business model
to convince the land owners.
[INAUDIBLE] incentive.
Once we have incentive, that
mean the owner [INAUDIBLE]
will get advantage
as a land owner
when you want to value land.
Both land owners and
community leaders
want that their interest
to be safeguarded
and their voices to be heard.
They insisted that
their rights to plan
the future of the kampong should
be acknowledged and integrated
in the planning and
decision making process.
They have to follow
the [INAUDIBLE],
the voice of the
people of [INAUDIBLE].
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
Dr. Shuhana Shamsuddin, a
professor in urban design,
shared her thoughts
on the way forward
in transforming the place.
The future development
of Kampong Bharu
will be more realistic
if they were to push it
on an incremental basis.
But this will be done when
and if the owners are ready.
If plans proceed,
Kampong Bharu will be
transformed on a massive scale.
While the redevelopment
is designed
for economic and
social sustainability,
it may, in the end, benefit few.
Without a collective
agreement from engaged members
of the community, the roadmap
to a sustainable future
of the kampong
remains uncertain.
Despite the challenge,
sustainability
of an urban village
is hinged on adapting
to change while securing
the economic, social,
and cultural values
of the place.
The impact of the
redevelopment depends
on how people are
informed about and engaged
in the education of economic
and social benefits.
Giving greater
voice to the people
is such [INAUDIBLE]
villages could better
align city
redevelopment objective
with the interests and
values of people living
in the traditional enclave.
The road to a
sustainable development
could be paved
effectively by integrating
the principle for inclusive
urban development,
adopting a place specific
planning approach,
considering rights
and ownership issues,
planning for equity
and community benefits,
and empowering community
through public participation
and engagement.
A framework for
future development
should allow for a place
to transform naturally
according to the current
needs and aspiration
of the local inhabitants.